so why are the media still madmen
apparently well the rest of Corporate
America has moved on we'll talk about
that plus the breaking news on the
Hillary Russia dossier pretty shocking
stuff and the JFK files are released and
we check the mailbag so lots coming up
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
so the big news as of yesterday was that
NBC correspondent and fabled
investigative journalist mark halperin
the guy who wrote Game Change and he was
about to write a new book about the
Trump campaign that was gonna be turned
into a series by HBO that he had been
apparently responsible for in an
innumerable number and allegedly of
incidents of sexual harassment or
assault where he would press himself up
against women with his genitals
where he would grope them where he would
where he would say things that were
wildly inappropriate I want to talk
about that and I want to talk about the
widespread nature of this thing in the
media and it does seem to be worse in
the media than it is in for example
corporate America at least by the
numbers and by the evidence and at least
by anecdotal evidence talk about all of
that in just a second but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
quip so the toothbrush that I use is a
equipped toothbrush the reason that I
use the quipped toothbrush is number one
because it is super effective in
cleaning up my teeth and making them
feel clean number two because if they if
you don't use a good toothbrush and and
and you get a bunch of plaque that can
actually affect your heart health
according to many studies and finally
because it's easy to travel with and the
brush heads are easily replaceable so
qyp is great for all of these things
it's sort of like if if there were an
iPhone but or a toothbrush it's just
it's it's really well designed it's it's
small it's easily travel you put the
battery right inside it it doesn't take
up a ton of space on your counter and it
works really really well it is one of
the Time magazine best inventions of
2016 it starts with just $25 right now
go to get quip comm slash capiro to get
your first refill pack free so the way
that it works is that you can subscribe
to receive new brush heads and a dentist
recommended three month plan for just
five bucks including free shipping so
you don't have to worry about you forgot
to replace the brush head and now it's
eight months later and you're still
using the same brush head which is
really gross they will send you the
replacement brush heads when you
subscribe go to get quick calm slash
Shapiro's again to get your first refill
pack free with a clip electric
toothbrush that's your first refill pack
free at get quip comm slash Shapiro the
toothbrush itself starts at just 25
bucks
g-e-t q uip comm get quip comm slash
Shapiro make sure that you are as
healthy as you can be and equip is the
best way to do it okay so I'm gonna
start today by talking about the the
Halperin allegation so there are a bunch
of people who have now come forward
bunch of women have now come
an accused mark halperin of sexual
harassment and/or assault now one of the
problems is people conflating these two
things because you know I think this as
a society we just need to be careful
about what we call things for legal
reasons so sexual assault is where
someone is legitimately threatening to
commit battery on you right it's
actually battery if someone grabs you
against your will but it is assault they
call it sexual assault if you are
threatening to do that so that is one
thing sexual harassment is where I guess
you're telling dirty jokes at the office
and sexual harassment there there's some
fuzzy lines with regard to sexual
harassment because you can tell the same
joke to two women and one of them may
take it offensively and another may not
or a woman may hear the same joke from
two men and one may tell it offensively
and one may not so sexual harassment is
a little bit more fuzzy there's certain
things that are clearly sexual
harassment right a guy coming up to a
girl and telling her she has a nice ass
clearly sexual harassment not
necessarily sexual harassment if a guy
says a dirty joke just to a group of
people and there's some women there or
if he says it to a woman and he had told
the guy five minutes before so you know
I just want to keep these distinctions
in mind what is not in question is that
Mark Halperin is allegedly responsible
the the NBC News reporter that he is
allegedly responsible for some serious
sexual harassment / sexual assault so in
a new report from the Washington Post
one in Diana May alleges that she was
sexually harassed by Halperin back in
1994 when she was a young researcher at
ABC News according to me she is that she
had asked Halpern for help with a story
and he had come into his and he had her
come into his office come over here she
recalled him saying sit down and I'll
give you the information he then
motioned to his lap and she was shocked
and wanted to refuse but she continued
is she considered how Halpern was a
rising star as the political director at
ABC News at the time and was a favorite
of them World News Tonight anchor Peter
Jennings so not to injure her career she
reluctantly sat down on his lap where
she alleged that he was in full we shall
say that he he was in full flight mode
she said that this routine occurred
three or four times leaving her confused
shaken and ashamed she said I didn't
know what to do he was important he
wasn't my superior but he was suit
clearly in a superior position of mine I
didn't say anything I know how to at the
time I knew it was wrong another accuser
Emily Miller has also come forward after
the CNN allegations were published
he has been basically tossed out of the
of the industry his
was cancelled he was fired apparently
she suggested that she was attacked by
by Mark Halperin as well she was once a
producer at ABC News where Halperin
spends a good portion of his career so
presumably you know that took place when
they were both at the network and
there's a you know this is not the only
allegation there's another allegation
from CNN that there's a woman at CNN
who's a former producer and she says
that she was trying to interview with
Halperin and Halperin offered her a
business card she showed up and she says
I don't quite remember what we talked
about I do remember him asking me to sit
down next to him on the couches during
an interview I thought it was awkward to
sit on the couch when I was perfectly
comfortable sitting in the chair across
from his desk but I complied and I also
remember him sitting a little too close
to me at one point it felt a bit
uncomfortable and I stood up to thank
him for the meeting that's when he
leaned in tried to kiss me and attempted
to do a bit more I didn't want to offend
the man in charge of political
programming at ABC News and I tried to
be courteous and apologetic and
practically ran out of the office she
said that she finally landed a position
at CNN on Larry King Live and she said
she would never book Halperin again as
sort of her minor revenge on all of this
so one of the you know one of the things
that I think is worth asking here is why
this seems so common in Hollywood and in
the media at large so I've already
talked about the Hollywood values you
know the casting couch mentality this
idea that women are expected to sleep
with directors and producers in order to
get jobs and the reality that many women
do do that in order to get jobs or do
that in convincing themselves that it's
fine thing to do when they're really
doing it in order to get jobs that's not
putting the blame on the woman that's
putting the blame on the man and saying
this is a system in which women have had
to work and many women have gone along
with it rather than speaking up about it
which is clearly true on any objective
level one of the questions you have to
ask is why this is happening so much in
the media and it appears to have happens
pretty much every woman in the media
right here is a panel from from SE Cupp
over on CNN and here's is a panel of
women and they basically all say that
they've been sexually harassed I'm in
this little room and I put my ear in to
hear him and he says welcome se I just
want you to know I've been calling you C
cup around the office I thought you're
an idiot what an idiot I'm miked you're
miked you're saying this over on an
onion
your piece and I thought okay we're not
even in the same location and I'm pretty
sure that was just sexual harassment to
sexualize a body part of mine joke about
it where other people could hear it on
the first day okay and all of these
women's hold very similar stories and
these kind of things do happen a lot at
media companies I've worked with a lot
of women at media companies who are in
the talent side of the business and
because beauty is a commodity in in TV
it just is okay that's the way this
works in media that means that there are
a lot of men who think they can get away
with saying nasty things to women about
their body parts or about how they look
you know again there are certain people
who like Alecia Krauss is like a sister
to me so we make jokes with each other
all the time but I would never make
jokes anyone else because we're close
friends but Alicia has gotten sexually
harassed by people who are at former
companies and she's told me about this
and it's very very common and one of the
questions that you have to here's
Kristen powers making making the same
sort of claim you know I've been
harassed so many times I can't even
count and I and I don't come out and
publicly talk about them in large part
because it's still true I think that
most women feel and I feel that you will
pay a price for it and that when you
look at the women who have come out
certainly in the media the people have
made the accusations about raat against
Roger Ailes for example really I think
with one exception which would be making
Kelly the rest of them have I haven't
been able to be employed again and she's
correct about this so there are a few
things that I think are worth saying
about why this happened so much in the
media and also where is this fuzzy space
because there is a problem for women
okay if you're sexually harassed in the
workplace and you go to HR and it's a
he-said she-said situation unless it's
legally actionable it makes it very
difficult for anybody to do anything
about it not all sexual harassment
situations are legally actionable even
against the company because remember the
standard legally for sexual harassment
against a company or a discriminatory
working but excuse me a discriminatory
work environment is not an individual
guy sexually harassing you it's the
creation of an entire element right it's
the creation of an entire business
environment that is sexually harassing
that's what you can sue a company for if
a random guy works for a company and
sexually harasses you you couldn't sue
Daily wire if one person at Daily wire
sexually harassed a girl you couldn't
sue the entire company you could report
it to HR and then HR would have a
responsibility to look into it but in or
to meet the legal standard for suing the
company itself you would actually have
to show a legally harassing environment
that had been promulgated by the office
now in the media there's something else
that's happening and it happens in
religious institutions too very powerful
institutions where people feel like they
have something to lose our places where
they are less likely to speak out so I
was talking with with my business
partner Jeremy born yesterday Jeremy
used to work in Hollywood a lot and he
took a lot of meetings in Hollywood he
was telling me about one meeting he had
with a studio head where this particular
studio had was talking about a
particular actress with his female
assistants in the room and this studio
had apparently said about the actress
you know I'd bleep her wouldn't you
bleep her he turned to the girl he said
wouldn't you bleep her you know if you
had if you had a bleep wouldn't you
bleep her and they so even if you didn't
have a bleep you would you do this to
her and describe the very graphic sexual
act and Jeremy said to me you know one
of the things in Hollywood is that this
is so common that it took him by
surprise
because he felt like if I were in a
Walmart board room you know the the
girl's name was Juliet or something then
this wouldn't be called Walmart anymore
this would be called Juliet Mart right
if the head of G if the head of Walmart
had said that - Juliet some assistant
this would now be called Juliet enlarge
she sue him for sexual harassment and
she win and she'd take the entire
company away but in Hollywood it's
SuperDuper common and that's because a
lot of people are making this trade-off
decision that it is not worth speaking
up because they're afraid of the career
ramifications so that means that two
things have to change one is that we
actually have to fight against a culture
that suggests that women can't get jobs
anymore if they accuse someone of sexual
harassment or sexual assault right that
definitely has to be fought and you know
the point that is being made here by
Kirsten powers that a lot of women who
complain about this stuff and then
blackballed that people think that are
their litigation risk that's absolutely
true and that's why we have to have hard
lines harder lines we as a society have
to sit down and decide what constitutes
legitimate sexual harassment that is
worthy of review so that we can tell
when a woman is actually complaining for
the right reasons or when she's
complaining because she's being
oversensitive you know in 90% of cases
it'll be the right reasons and 10% of
cases it may be because she's
oversensitive but the problem is that
without any hard lines it's very easy
for people to shy away from it and just
say oh she's oversensitive I'm not
hiring her she's a litigation risk why
would we do that so the first thing that
has to be done
is we have to some draw some hard lines
of society and the second thing that has
to be done is we have to determine for
as a society you know we have to
reevaluate what is worth subjecting
yourself to in order to get ahead in a
particular business or in a particular
institution I'll talk about that in just
a second but first I want to say thank
you to our friends over at us CCA so us
concealed-carry Association is of course
the place that gives you everything you
need to know about concealed and carry
and they help protect you against a
situation in which God forbid you have
to shoot somebody in a home invasion
scenario and now the police show up what
do you do and who covers the cost of the
lawyers u.s. concealed carry Association
helps you with all those things right
now they are giving away a 20-17
concealed carry and family defense guide
from the u.s. concealed carry
Association it is 100% free
in it you will learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting the safest and
most dangerous places sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun especially if you have small
children and a whole lot more so 164
pages of great info comes with a bonus
audio version as well
so you can listen in your car it's 100%
free and right now you will also get a
bonus home defense checklist when you go
to defend my family now calm thats
defend my family now calm right now for
a hundred percent free instant access
this is something you need to have in
your house and you need to read its
again defend my family now.com thats
defend my family now to calm you seca
doing great work for gun owners the
country over okay so from the final
point I want to make her as an
institutional one there is a draw to the
camera okay there's it one of the things
the reasons this is happening in the
media a lot is because there's a draw
out of the camera and men know this and
men are exploitative if given power men
will be exploitative because anyone in a
position of power will be exploitative
women in positions of power tend not to
be sexually exploitative in the same way
that men are because men's sex drives
are not the same as women sex drives men
with power will to base themselves and
to base other people for sex more
commonly than women well the camera
offers an unnamed power so the reason
you see sexual assault covered up so
often in religious institutions is the
idea that the people who are committing
the sexual assault have a direct
pipeline to God and so they have a
unique capacity to to pass on that power
to others right and so people feel like
well if this person is saying it they
must be more moral they must have a
special
you know direct line to God and
therefore there's nothing that I can say
about and this happens a lot in
religious communities
it happens in public schools because you
know there's a lot of small children but
when in Hollywood it happens a lot more
than anywhere else I think and it
happens a lot more in the media than
anywhere else I think also because of
the power of the camera so it's not just
you know a lot of these women who want
to appear on TV you know they want to
appear on TV not because the money is so
great but because there is something
magical about a camera in a mess you
know in a mass cultural phenomenon it's
something we have to get over as a
society the camera has a certain power
you know there are these girls gone wild
kind of softcore pornography videos that
have become very very popular and
basically all they are is this company
goes to places like Cancun and they show
up with a camera and they say the girls
take off your take off your show us your
bleep right and then girls will do it
right girls will do it is that sexual
harassment by the cameraman well yeah I
mean it is but girls will do it because
there's a camera there the camera is not
magical the camera is not magical the
reason that if was an executive all Mart
said that he'd immediately be sued for
sexual harassment is because there's
nothing magical happening in that
boardroom you're selling thing you're
selling like you know baby clothes but
the presence of the camera the
possibility of the glittering fame the
possibility of Tinseltown has been true
for a hundred years it is it is a draw
for everyone including women and men you
use that draw in order to get some place
that's something that has to end and as
the media fractures I hope that we're
going to see less of this not more you
know when there are a limited number of
cameras available then people will do
anything to get in front of those
cameras as the media fractures I hope
that this will become less and less
common specifically because you can have
a camera on your own put it up on
YouTube and never have to worry about
moving through an executive office with
Mark Halperin gesturing for you to sit
on his lap we need to get over the
romance with the camera and that's true
for everyone viewers and and
participants alike because again the
camera does not offer some sort of
magical power okay I want to talk about
the Clinton Trump dossier and what
exactly it means so this has been a big
story this week and my opinion on sort
of been evolving over the course of
weeks at the beginning of the week I
thought maybe this is a little bit
overblown then more evidence came out I
thought this is really not particularly
overblown and now I think it
not overblown but some people are taking
it a step too far in their analysis so
I'm trying to be as intellectually
honest as I possibly can about the
information that we have about this this
steel dossier and the information that
came out earlier this week that Hillary
Clinton and her campaign had basically
funded it so here is the backdrop the
backdrop is that for nine months we have
been hearing that Donald Trump is the
president of the United States because
he colluded with Russia and no one has
been able to define what exactly
collusion means right that the pieces of
evidence that have been presented are
essentially seven
I mean named the pieces of evidence here
in favor of the quote-unquote Trump
Russia collusion theory so piece of
evidence number one is that trumps head
bizarrely warm things about Russia piece
of evidence number two was that poem
anaphoric Trump's former campaign
manager had very close ties with the
Russian government piece of evidence
number three was that his former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
had some close ties with with Russia
today and apparently with the Russian
government fourth piece of evidence is
that former trump foreign policy adviser
Carter page apparently had close ties
with the Russian government fifth piece
of evidence was that Donald Trump jr.
apparently approved of a meeting with a
Russian connected lawyer under the
auspices of being from the Russian
government and wanting Trump to win
these revenues number six was that Trump
fired FBI to director James Comey and
then went on national television and
basically said that he did it because
Comey was pressuring him on Russia and
the final piece of evidence it was this
week that Trump's data firm which was
owned by the Mercer family called the
Cambridge analytical had apparently
reached out to Julian Assange who is
apparently according to most accounts a
Russian cutout in an attempt to gain
access to Hillary's missing emails that
is all the evidence none of that
evidence is final evidence of actual
collusion between the Trump campaign and
Russia that's a lot of smoke but no fire
and for a year we've been hearing the
fire is coming and there's been no
evidence of the fire yet now they're
saying by the way the Mueller's big
report is supposed to break before
Thanksgiving which will be a media
feeding frenzy but if he doesn't have
any more evidence than that there's
nothing there
so for a year we've been hearing Trump
has to be impeached Trump is corrupt
Trump Russia Trump Russia Trump Russia
Trump Russia it's the end of the world
Trump Russia okay now with that as
backdrop here is what we found out this
week about Hillary Clinton's campaign
and the Russians so for months members
of the Democratic Party and Hillary
Clinton campaign lied apparently lied
about whether they had funded the
creation
an anti-trump Oppo file called the steel
dossier the steel dossier we all found
out publicly about in January that was
the the dossier that BuzzFeed released
that included all sorts of wild
allegations some of which have been
confirmed about meetings between Trump
officials and Russian officials and some
of which have have yet to be confirmed
and our frivolous at best the the stuff
about from being peed on by Russian
processes and such you know all of that
was released by BuzzFeed in early
January the only reason that we found
out about it was because we now know
that that it was being passed around
Washington and that James Comey had
presented a two-page summary of some of
the charges in there to President Trump
himself that's why BuzzFeed released it
okay so the Democrats said they had not
been behind that dossier we now found
out this week that they lied and that in
fact mark Elias who is a lawyer for the
Hillary Clinton campaign had basically
funneled the money to Fuzion GPS to go
compiled the dossier the person who
compiled the dossier under democratic
auspices was Christopher Steele
Christopher Steele his wife the steel
dossier is former mi6 spy he went over
to Russia and then he had talks with a
bunch of people in the Kremlin
apparently the allegation is that he
passed the money that possibly American
money was passed to the Russian
government in order to secure
information about Donald Trump the file
itself according to Bayern New York of
the Washington Examiner includes several
sources from the Kremlin including a
senior Russian Foreign Ministry figure a
former top-level Russian intelligence
officer still active inside the Kremlin
and a senior Russian financial official
now let's say that all those people had
met with Donald Trump jr. and provided
him information everyone would say
collusion collusion collusion collusion
impeachment right Hillary Clinton
actually did that if you cut out the
middleman what you're seeing here is the
Hillary Clinton campaign paid the
Russian government or worked at the
Russian government to find a PO against
Donald Trump that's the exact allegation
that is being made against the Trump
campaign right so ironic at best and
criminal at worst and I'm not the only
one saying this jonathan turley
professor over at Georgetown of law he
says the allegations against Hillary
Clinton thus far are more criminal than
those against President Trump it's good
to have something that's more
recognizable as a criminal allegation
you know the as you know I've been very
skeptical about the right past Russian
collusion claims as being a criminal
matter even though I supported the
appointment of the special counsel after
Comey was fired
I've been cautioning and many others
have that it really isn't a crime to
collude and in the same sense it
wouldn't be a crime to receive
information on the Trump side from a
foreign national but the allegations
against the Clintons could potentially
be criminal doesn't mean that they are
criminal the $500,000 given to Bill
Clinton might have been innocent the
timing it just might have been horrible
but that would be a cognizable crime if
a linkage was found in the same way the
allegation of the dossier does involve a
potential violation of federal law the
federal election commission Act requires
campaigns to state a purpose for any
money spent over about $200 to extort of
have an item description for each of
those amounts there isn't an item
description for this law firm for the
amount of money that is being alleged to
be given to this research okay so two
things so this is a perfect case of what
about is him in the sense that what
Hillary Clinton did here was wrong if
the allegations were made about Donald
Trump would that make it right now would
it be okay now and this is where I think
that this this whole conversation seems
to go off the rails a little bit so
let's say that Hillary Clinton had been
elected president and we had found out
that she was colluding with the Russian
government to gain a poll on Trump and
she was president and that and then she
released all that oppo and that's why
she won let's say all of that had
happened
would we be crying impeachment right now
you bet your ass would be crying
impeachment right now we obviously be
crying impeachment right now so the
allegations the Democrats are making
about Trump are exactly those
allegations those have not yet been
proven there's no evidence for them so
just because Hillary did something that
is apparently criminal here or at least
allegedly criminal that does not
necessarily mean that nothing criminal
happened on the Trump side with that
said the allegations and the evidence
against Hillary Clinton's campaign much
much much stronger than anything that
has been proven by the against the Trump
campaign at this point I don't talk more
about this and I want to talk about the
Mueller investigation the impact on the
Muller investigation in just a second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at naturebox so everyone
wants to eat better when it comes to
snacks sometimes it feels like
everything is either taste great and is
one of bajillion calories or it is
boring and tasteless and you can eat
like this box of cardboard flakes so
that is where
your box comes in nature box has over a
hundred snacks that taste great and are
actually good for you
all snacks are made from high-quality
simple ingredients which means no
artificial colors flavors sweeteners you
can feel good about what you're eating
so around the office nature box is
supremely popular people have said I
asked them for their favorites people
said they really liked the vanilla bean
wafers and the dried mango as well as
the coffee kettle popcorn which I know
has been a big bestseller around the
office you are sure to find your snooze
snack obsession over at nature box they
do add new snacks every month inspired
by customer feedback go-to naturebox
calm and they will deliver nature box
right to your door there is no risk if
you ever try a snack that you don't like
don't eat it they'll replace it for free
right now nature box is offering my fans
50% off your first order when you go to
nature box common that is nature box
calm and Eicher box calm /ban for 50%
off your first order some pretty solid
discount nature box common and I can
show you the list of their snacks I mean
these are these are like it's it's
incredible I mean you're talking about
salt and vinegar veggie chips almond
butter apple and cinnamon oatmeal
crunchy BBQ twists garlic plantains I
mean the snacks the list is really
really long and it's all really really
good according to folks in the office
who have tried it so go over and check
out nature box.com and get 50% off your
first order okay so now let's talk about
how this impacts the Hillary thing
impacts the FBI investigation into
Donald Trump so on a political level it
impacts the investigation because now
we're all saying okay so what the hell
is it FBI investigating why weren't they
investigating Hillary Clinton why
weren't they investigating the Hillary
campaign and in fact they're now called
for the FBI to do exactly that the house
is going to call James Comey in front of
them again and ask him why he was not
investigating Hillary's collusion
right so that's point number one on a
political level you know this it makes
perfect sense to say okay everybody's
focused in on Trump really
Hillary was doing the same thing and
again I think that that's fair on a
political level I don't know that it
exonerates Trump from bad behavior if
Hillary was also behaving badly right
there were allegations that the
headquarters for Barry Goldwater were
bugged in 1964 by LBJ that didn't
necessarily get Richard Nixon off the
hook for doing the same thing at the
Watergate Hotel so let's talk a little
bit about the actual impact on the FBI
investigation so there are two elements
of the FBI in
negation that have been impacted one is
that apparently the FBI obtained FISA
warrants on Trump associates based on
allegations in the steel dossier the
allegation from people on the right is
that the FBI was there for colluding
with Hillary and Russia basically
Hillary was colluding with Russia to
come up with this dossier and then the
FBI took the unverified allegations in
the dossier through them by a FISA judge
and then got that FISA judge to sign off
on warrants to bug Carter page and Paul
Manafort basically that's that's the
allegation this seems to me evidence
list until the evidence actually arises
meaning that it is quite possible that
the FBI knew about the allegations in
the dossier and went independently
verified them not everything in the
dossier is false so people are saying
the dossier is complete crap some things
in the dossier are clearly complete crap
some things in the dossier are not right
there have been actual verified meetings
between some members of the Trump team
and some members of the you know people
who are associated with the Russian
government in any case not everything in
the dossier is not true so it is quite
possible that Comey
you know again I'm talking as a lawyer
so from a legal perspective you can
suspect whatever you want but it's only
what you can prove that matters from a
legal perspective there is no evidence
that James Comey took unverified
allegations from the dossier in cahoots
with Hillary and then proceeded to throw
them to a FISA judge that we could get
warrants on these guys okay second
allegation is that Comey
for political reasons basically
continued to fund the Steele dossier
after the after the seal after um
Steele's name had been released and
after the Democrats had stopped funding
the Steele dossier that he found this
stuff interesting and for political
reasons he wanted to continue the
funding into it it's also possible for
legal reasons he wanted to continue the
funding into it because he felt that
there was actual illegality taking place
and he wanted to investigate it after
all he was the head of the FBI so both
of those don't see the evidence for that
yet and I am someone who is deeply
skeptical of James Comey and thought he
was absolutely wrong last July when he
exonerated Hillary Clinton I also
thought he was wrong when he reopened in
October I think he was a garbage FBI
director and and but that still does not
prove the allegations that are being
made here final allegation that's being
made is or at least a claim that's being
made is by the editors over at The Wall
Street Journal so they write today
the fusion Noons means that the FBI's
role in Russia's election interference
probe must now be investigated even as
the FBI and Justice insists that mr.
Miller's probe prevents them from
cooperating with congressional
investigators so a
and I'm not sure that a anything beyond
suspicion unverified suspicions suggest
that the FBI was not doing its job in
the Russian probe Muller is a former FBI
director and for years he worked closely
with mr. Comey okay that's been true
forever so if you're saying the mother
should recuse himself on that basis that
was true from the very start and I'm not
sure why that is now coming to the floor
now it says it is no slur against mr.
Miller's integrity to say he lacks the
critical distance to conduct a credible
probe of the bureau he ran for a dozen
years again I'm not sure that that you
know I'm not sure that that proves the
point I mean you could just as easily
say that as a former FBI director he
knows where all the bodies are buried
and says he could best serve the country
by resigning to prevent further
political turmoil over that conflict of
interest so my opinion on this is that
this seems to be jumping the gun right
suggesting that Muller has to go because
he knows Comey if he felt that way that
was true months ago suggesting he has to
go because now the FBI is is being
accused of things for which there's no
evidence yet you know that also seems to
me to be jumping the gun at best to say
that the entire investigation should
just be shut down on the basis that both
parties did it that's at least a more
honest opinion on what's happening here
and again I think that this
investigation is going to afford my
strong hunch is that Muller is not gonna
find anything then what we know is what
we know and that Muller is gonna come
forward with a couple of things the
media will blow out of proportion but
there'll be no hard evidence of
collusion between the Trump campaign and
Russia and then this will all be over
that is my strong hunch on all of this
but I wanted to give you as objective a
perspective on this as I can which is
that there appears to be criminal
activity or at least alleged criminal
very very strong evidence of criminal
activity from the Hillary camp there's
not nearly as strong evidence in the
Trump camp I don't know this is an
excuse to shut down the Special Counsel
investigation or to fire Muller that's
that's my basic take on all of this okay
I want to talk about the I do want to
talk about the male that well Deneuve
mailbag also I want to talk about some
policy implications of this continuing
and ongoing Republican infighting in
just a second but first you're gonna
have to go over to Daily wire calm so
for $9.99 a month you can subscribe to
daily wire.com when you do that you get
the rest of our show live on video you
get the rest of Michael Knowles's show
live on video and Andrew Clavin show
live on video you can be part of my
mailbag today so if you have a question
and you want an answer in the next 20
minutes now is the time for you to go
subscribe for $9.99 a month over at Daly
why
if you want the annual subscription you
can get that for 99 bucks so you get it
for cheaper plus you get the leftist
here's hot or cold tumbler the greatest
of all beverage vessels it will make
your life better in every conceivable
way you have a dog that is sick
this will make your life better I don't
know why it just it just does it's just
a fact of the of reality in any case go
and go and subscribe right now plus
they're gonna be benefits for the
Shapiro store which is indeed coming
I've been assured that it will be coming
before Christmas okay another thing that
I want to talk about is YouTube so you
need to go over and subscribe to YouTube
the reason you need to subscribe to our
youtube channel is because in a very
short while we're gonna be
live-streaming a special daily wire
edition of stranger things in honor of
the season two premiere and I'm gonna in
less than three minutes I get everyone
up to speed on season one here is a clip
of it we will not share the whole thing
until a little bit later today
in the meantime choice gets mysterious
calls from will and they all go looking
for him only to find 11:11 explains that
will is trapped in the upside down
prisoner - you guessed it gang the demo
Gorgon think of the upside down like a
flea walking on a tightrope and then
somersaulting into the other dimension
okay so you're a flea you're playing D&D
and then you cross over to the demagogue
in and you're upside down okay so if you
like that sort of thing
then go over and subscribe and that is
not the funniest part of the video there
there's some pretty hilarious parts of
the video if you want to see how this
ends up for me and Clavin and Noel's
head over to YouTube subscribe to our
Channel and for the love of God ring the
bell to get a notification when this
goes live it later today or risk missing
Michael Knowles in a dress which I gotta
say knows in a dress like every video
and he's just so comfortable doing it
like every time we ask him
Michael we dress up as a girl he's like
of course and we don't even have to ask
him sometimes it's weird you just
walking around the office dressed as 11
I'm not sure why that is
it's a weird office okay so you should
also go over to I Towne iTunes or
SoundCloud just wanna listen to the rest
of the show today we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
okay so with all the Republican
infighting that is still taking place
it's interesting I'm listening to a lot
of people who I really respect people
with whom I agree largely on their
assessment of President Trump in terms
of character and it seems to me that
they are missing a key point a lot of
them with regard to the Jeff Flake
fallout so there's still a lot of
fallout from Jeff Flake and his speech
on the Senate floor in which he ripped
into Trump and suggested the Republican
Party had now become prisoner to trump
and Bannon and that is I don't think
that's again I think that's an overreach
of the situation
their suggestion seems to be that if
you're critical of Trump in any way that
they will that everyone in the
Republican Party will come after you in
primary you and finish you I don't think
that's right I don't think that's right
I think that you can be critical of
Trump when he does things and I think it
can be critical of him as president I
think it can say he's doing great damage
to the country as president for some of
the things that he is saying and doing
in terms of undermining American unity I
think and say all of those things as
long as you say also that Trump and you
are on the same page when it comes to
some of these agenda items you know that
you are I mean Jeff Flake voted 95
percent of the time with President Trump
in the Senate but didn't focus on that
at all he spends all of his time talking
about all the downsides of Trump and
none of his time talking about you know
the things that Trump is doing right and
I think you do have to give a more
objective view of Trump rather than the
overall see here's the thing you know we
could talk about the overall I did all
the time I talked about the overall
aspect of Trump during the 2016 election
what when you when you were forced to
come to a conclusion about Trump you
were forced to come to a I'll vote for
him or I won't vote for him but now the
question is not do you support Trump or
do you not support Trump because what
does that even mean in practical terms
like I don't even understand this idea
of I don't support Trump right now maybe
you don't support some of the stuff he
does but your support means nothing to
him
right you're not giving him money really
you're not voting for him we're not
gonna vote again on Trump when I can
have a referendum on Trump again for
another three years so what does it mean
to support Trump this is why I say you
can support some of the stuff he does
and really not support some of the stuff
that he does and that seems to me as a
senator your job it doesn't seem to me
that you need to do an overall
assessment of Trump as president every
single day it seems to me that you can
say when Trump does stuff like this it's
really gross or I think President Trump
has character flaws that are leading him
down a really dark path here and I wish
he would do better but this idea
that you have to go out every day and
you have to talk about trumping a boob
you know and that's and that's the
entirety of your comment
that's what's ticking off the base
because the implication is that it is so
eminently obvious that you'd have no
support that everyone who supports him
is a dolt and that I think is why people
are offended by Jeff Flake and that is
why also I think that you know that this
this notion that the party has now been
taken over by Trump to such an extent
that good conservatives can't be elected
ignores the fact that you can be a good
conservative and still elide the Trump
issue or you don't even have to alive
the Trump issue so long as you're
willing to speak to speak objectively
about what Trump is doing right when he
cuts regulations that's a good thing
when you say the Trump administration is
cutting regulations that's great
his response to charlottesville was
abominable I think most people on the
right go okay I can live with that
assessment what they can't live with is
you going out there and saying that
Trump is completely unfit for the office
in the sense that you will never support
him under any circumstances whatever the
policy ramifications because that is
where that that's where you go bridge
too far right I don't support Trump as a
person I'm not a big fan of Trump as a
person but some of the things that he's
doing are good things and I support
those things so I think that that's it
that's a better assessment of the
situation okay
meanwhile the Republicans still aren't
able to pass anything and again that's
not totally on President Trump but her
leadership would be helpful here but
we're gonna get what we're gonna get
Nancy Pelosi says that by Christmas
we'll have a DREAM Act Justin Amash is
complaining about the budget that just
passed the house is a major budget that
that continues to increase the deficit
Nancy Pelosi says we will have a DREAM
Act by Christmas so things are going
swimmingly I think President Trump is
inclined to be supportive he said he is
I take him at his word
and that because the American people
support the dreamers not because we were
so persuasive but because the American
people support the dreamers so I'm
optimistic that we'll celebrate
hopefully Thanksgiving but we're likely
Christmas with a dream that past you
said that'll be great we'll get to the
end of the year and the only major
legislative achievement will be the
DREAM Act the very thing that Trump ran
against pretty amazing stuff again
that's because of Republican disunity
but you know that as I say before
disunity is is not really because of
Trump this disunity pre-state predated
Trump
Trump is a symptom as well as a cause
okay time for some things that I like
and then some things that I hate and
then we will get to the mailbag and I
want to actually take some time with the
mailbag today so things that I like so
my daughter has been very into Sleeping
Beauty lately there is this is sort of
the second wave of good of very solid
Disney movies the first wave is
Pinocchio and Bambi and the second wave
is Cinderella and Sleeping Beauty so
there there is still classics but
there's sort of more minor classics one
of the things that's great about
Sleeping Beauty is that the entire thing
is basically scored to check Hoffs key
music so even the famous song in the
middle is from Tchaikovsky's ballet and
the animation is very stylized so my dad
really dislikes it I think some of it is
actually pretty cool-looking my daughter
for some reason that frightens me is a
big fan of Maleficent so we went to we
went to the Disney the Disney Store
yesterday and she actually she's getting
a big kick out of dressing I have a
Maleficent costume she's getting a big
kick out of dressing up as Maleficent in
any case here here's some of the preview
for Sleeping Beauty a beautiful maiden
with a spellbinding destiny
sixteenth birthday she would prick her
finger on the spindle of a spinning
wheel from this slumber you shall wake
when true love's kiss the special ring
beautiful
okay so one of the nice things about
sleeping beauty is sleeping beauty is
one of the last Disney movies really I
mean camping in like the 50s it's one of
the last Disney movies where the Prince
actually does anything right thing about
this like every Disney movie the Prince
doesn't do crap right it really since
the 80s and 90s the prince is basically
just a guy who stands there and every
heroine is every Disney Princess is the
is the is the heroine who saves herself
right Pocahontas saves the world Mulan
saves the world in Tangled you have
Flynn Rider who's more active which is
why I like tangled a lot but frozen
there isn't like the Kristoff that movie
makes no sense I really dislike frozen
very strongly I think frozen is terrible
but but all of the modern Disney movies
Little Mermaid the most active
characters are all the women like by far
they're they're the females it seems to
me that you can have more than one
active character in a film which again
is why I like tangled in Sleeping Beauty
Prince Phillip actually does stuff okay
it it turns out that there's a whole
class of people who watch movies who are
young but are not appealed to by a lot
of the Disney stuff they're called boys
they exist okay and I know that Disney
makes movies like like cars but they're
not boys they're cars right there
inanimate objects who have male voices
okay they're the Disney Princesses and
then every every movie about a guy is
about a car writer it's monsters into
monster right at no point does a human
male ever have the capacity to save
anything in these films and this is
something that annoys me generally
because again the history of Western
civilization is replete with sexism it
is also replete with men and saving
women okay Western civilization and the
building of Western civilization is
largely predicated on the idea that men
have to protect women so if you like
chivalry if you like the idea that a man
has to protect a woman then it seems to
me that you should like a movie like
Sleeping Beauty where a man is
protecting a woman okay that it's it's
it's ridiculous to me that we can't make
movies like this anymore okay other
things that I like so yesterday and I'm
president Trump did something that I
thought was was quite good and I think
is useful he got a little sentimental
over his brother and he was talking
about the opioid epidemic and he was
talking specifically about how
alcoholism ruined his brother's life I
learned myself I had a brother Fred
great guy best-looking guy best
much better than mine but he had a
problem he had a problem with alcohol
and he would tell me don't drink don't
drink
he was substantially older and I
listened to him and I respect it
but he would constantly tell me don't
drink ok so again I think that you know
this is this is good stuff
from-from Trump and I wish he would
actually see more of this right when he
uses his voice in favor of useful things
I think that it's great
ok time for a couple of quick things
that I hate so the JFK documents have
now been released Rachel Maddow was
ridiculing President Trump over the JFK
documents because they were not all with
how they're not all released a trumpet
enema and released all of them then he
didn't release all of them and and
here's Rachel Maddow going after him for
it the president the White House they
appear to have really thought it was
gonna be released day right they did the
tweets they sent Trump to do his act
like JFK act on the rope line at the
Love Field tarmac yesterday and
everything but when the clock struck
midnight last night and no documents
were released and then this morning
rolled around and nothing was released
and then today rolled on and nothing was
released finally NBC news this afternoon
got u.s. intelligence officials to admit
to them that yeah the work didn't the
documents spelling out what's supposed
to be redacted that didn't get finished
or maybe the dog ate it it wasn't ready
to go this is a stupid criticism to me
again I think the Trump should always be
more careful when he says things like
I'm gonna release all the document and
then he doesn't but this is a dumb
criticism here's what we do know from
these from these JFK documents so the
JFK documents don't show anything new
except for the fact that we now know
that that Lee Harvey Oswald apparently
was having conversations in broken
Russian with the head of the KGB's
assassination unit in the months leading
up to the assassination okay so that is
not a grave shock it's also not clear
that they were plotting JFK's murder
it looks like Lee Harvey Oswald's kind
of a crazy person and if you know
anything about Lee Harvey Oswald you
know he tried to claim asylum in Russia
he went to Russia for several years he
tried to
asylum in Cuba just just weeks before he
shot JFK he wasn't communist okay he
wasn't a communist form a military
member who turned communist he married a
girl from Minsk and he had attempted to
assassinate an American general actually
in Dallas beforehand and and that had
failed one of the things that I hate
about all of the JFK conspiratorial
theories is the the willingness to
ignore the fact that you have that Lee
Harvey Oswald was a communist was
motivated by communism to kill JFK in
fact Jackie Kennedy famously stated
after after she found out who as Wald
was that she was sad that JFK had to be
killed by a silly little communist why
couldn't he die for something like civil
rights so the left immediately attempted
to swerve this into a critique of
America JFK's assassination led into
this leftist critique of America as a
terrible place that couldn't stand the
Camelot that the shining city on the
hill that JFK stood for and they and it
was it was all of our collective
American guilt that had killed JFK I
hate this crap it wasn't it was a commie
and a piece of crap commie who was
attempting to reach out to the Russian
government
it is also amazing one of the pieces of
documentation here suggest that the the
Russian government suspected the KGB
suspected that LBJ was behind the JFK
assassination which shows a couple of
things one that they probably were not
interested in assassinating JFK and then
leave Lee Harvey Oswald acted on his own
and number two that when you are when
you are a member of a fascist state that
your perception of how the government
works is largely based on your own
governmental system and your own your
own perception of how governments work
so because in Russia you know future
leaders were often assassinated by prior
leaders and vice versa they thought okay
well if JFK died it was probably cuz
there's some sort of coup attempt that's
not how it works in the United States
and it just goes to show you when your
men and when your mind is corrupted by
bad governments that's where you end up
okay time for the mailbag so it says
hello Ben if you were suddenly arrested
what would your friends and family
assume you had done honestly my friends
and family would probably assume that I
had pissed off the wrong authorities and
that I was being arrested for political
reasons that probably be the most likely
scenario
Haden's has been as a California
conservative I see our state legislature
representatives and Senators constantly
passing legislation that directly harms
California it seems the only way to
combat this is to flip the state how do
we turn California into a red state
electing senator Shapiro would be a good
start well
good luck on that and as far as turning
California into a red state one of two
things is going to happen either people
are going to get wise to how terribly
things are being run and there will be a
movement toward the right which I could
see or alternatively things are gonna
get worse and worse and worse and worse
and the state will empty out and then
Republicans will come back in and retake
the state right that's it that's also a
significant possibility because that
will just take a little bit longer right
this is my theory of political
population movements is that Republicans
conservatives they move into an area
they immediately make it awesome they
they establish laws that protect
property rights and don't tax everybody
too much and then Democrats come in and
they decide to redistribute everything
they ruin it and so the Republicans I'll
leave and they go someplace that's
slightly crap you're in terms of climate
but they make it awesome anyway and then
the Democrats I'll follow them there and
then the Republicans leave so if that's
the case then eventually all the
Republicans will leave California which
is sort of happening and then the
Democrats will make it super crappy but
then won't be in the economy here's the
olive and then Republicans will reoccupy
the ruins of California in 50 years and
turn it red again Jackson says hey Ben
what would President Trump needs to do
in the next year for you to consider him
as having a successful presidential term
well I mean passing legislation be good
how about fulfilling some of his some of
his some of his promises reforming the
immigration system would be a good start
building the wall as he said he would
repealing Obamacare which he has not
done passing tax reform which he has not
done passing some religious protections
which he has not done any of those
things would be it would be good I'm not
going to say he had a successful
president she the presidency just cuz
the economy was good under him because
the economy wasn't bad in the second
term of Obama and he was not a
successful president in my view brad
says what is your opinion on Milton
Friedman so I really like Milton
Friedman you know I think that free to
choose a terrific book I disagree with
some of his opinions like universal
basic income
I think they lead to inflation and
freeze the economy in place in some ways
but I enjoyed Milton Friedman's work a
lot and his explanations of economics on
YouTube are fun to watch as well david
says you say the Shapiro story is coming
when as I said earlier it should be here
by Christmas if I am wrong then you can
lash me with wet noodle Timothy says Ben
besides the Bible in your religious
studies what books have you read that
it's helped solidify your solid faith in
Judaism
what book if any would you recommend to
a friend or acquaintance who's agnostic
keep up the great work so I've
recommended a lot of these books on the
show and some of them are not Jewish so
you know I've recommended things like
guide to the perplexed by Maimonides
this week but in more secular terms I
think that if you read a history of
Western civilization that that takes
into account religious thought it makes
you more of a believer in the
judeo-christian tradition at the very
least you know as far as believing these
specific claims of Judaism such as
revelation on Sinai you know there there
are a couple of good little little tomes
that I'll have to look up the titles of
because they're they're good I will say
that you know again anytime you say that
God spoke to humans you have to take a
certain leap of faith because that's
just the way things work and one of the
reasons that God created us was to was
to take that leap of faith so I don't
think it's out of balance to say that
God hides himself so we can take the
leap of faith man he says hello Ben I
saw a youtube video of you at 12 years
old playing the violin Larry King said
your dream must be the first Orthodox
rabbi in the Supreme Court is this still
an aspiration of yours no neither half
of that is actually an aspiration of
mine so I'm not really interested in
spending the time necessary to get some
eheh which is what it's called when you
want to join the rabbinate and sitting
on the Supreme Court well it would be
fun I gave up on that dream long ago
because there's no chance I would ever
be nominated or be confirmed for a seat
on the Supreme Court Urraco says what
are your favorite and least favorite
Halloween candies so and just candies in
general I am a a heathen so you have to
get a kosher version of this that comes
from Israel kosher skittles are
fantastic
as I've said before I love sour jelly
bellys these are my favorite candies and
actually there's somebody the Jelly
Belly factory is a fan who sent me a
bunch of Jelly Belly's and so I thank
him for that because we have been
enjoying that in the Shapiro household
those are my favorite at least favorite
Halloween can so first of all everyone
knows that that candy corn is garbage
everyone knows the time garbage there's
no one in no one in human history who's
ever eaten candy corn above the age of
seven all that candy corn just melts
it's gunk it coats your teeth it's
disgusting
other other candies that are bad first
of all there's no one worse than the
then the horrible woman on your street
from the hands out apples right the
horror like I love apples but if you
hand out apples as candy you're a bad
person
this is a if you're handing out like
figs and dates and what is this the 13
century figs and dates ooh we're gonna
have a candidate I have certain
objections to certain desserts generally
one of my bugaboos is fruitcakes
the idea of having me that people have
these fruit tarts and they have the the
custard and then they have the cut fruit
on top of it why would you ruin the
custard with the cut fruit on top of it
why would you do that fruit is fruit and
custard is custard why would you
possibly put the fruit on top of the
custard then it gets all gooey and
disgusting on top we have to scrape off
the fruit to get to the custard why
how'd you do this okay now you've got me
on a dessert rant all right Garrett it
says what are some must use in the next
10 years for a high school senior who
wants to be a senator one day college
selection getting connected things to
study etc okay so college selection you
have to go to a good college or have to
go to a great college getting connected
I would say that you have to do a lot of
things for free to be successful right
so you for me I wrote a lot for very
little money or for free for a long time
before I became successful in this arena
and you have to do a lot of those things
to make connections reach out to
everyone things to study you need to
read constantly you need to constantly
be updating yourself on topics so when
Russia is in the news you need to go and
you need to look up some books on Russia
and read books on Russia as I have said
before one of the weird things about
politics is that if you've read a book
on a subject this puts you in the top 2%
of Americans on the subject because most
people don't know anything about Russia
right and this is true certainly about
places like that a nice year right if
you're looking at nice year no one knows
anything about knives here no one knows
a thing if you read an article a knife
here you have suddenly become an expert
none neither so reading constantly is is
the solution and then obviously you have
to cultivate your ability with human
beings it's something that I've been
working on for years but it's not yet
conquered as my employees can tell you
Emanuel says hey Ben in the 2012 RNC
autopsy one of the main points was the
need for Republicans to do more outreach
to minority communities particularly
Latinos to ensure the party's long-term
survival how necessary do you think this
is as Latino conservative it seems like
the Republican brand is being poisoned
among Latino communities members thanks
to the president even among family
members were staunch Republicans so
here's the thing that I think is true it
is imperative that Republicans reach out
to members of the Latino community the
reach out to Latinos I recommended years
ago that Republicans start trying to
learn Spanish I have infamously been
attempting to learn Spanish for years
and failed dramatically in that task but
I do not think that the conservative
message is limited to white folks now
that said I think the attempt to buy off
Latinos within
raishin reform is stupid the Latino
community is very split on the idea that
all illegal immigrants have to be
legalized immediately that that all
illegal immigrants should be given
citizenship I think that you can take in
reasonable position on immigration and
Latinos will mostly agree with you or at
least many of them will agree with you
and I think the Latinos you know like
any other human being
and and maybe an outsize proportion
because there's an ounce size proportion
of religious Latinos believed in things
like personal responsibility and have
the capacity to believe in those things
so yeah I think it's a mistake the stuff
that I think really alienates Latinos
from President Trump is is way he talks
about Latinos not even the policy
prescriptions like when he says things
like his initial speech when he said
Mexican and Mexico is not sending us our
best they're sending us rapists and
murderers like no I mean that's a very
small percentage of the people who are
crossing there are certain people who
are but the vast majority of illegal
immigrants I know I live in LA half the
people here are illegal immigrants most
of them are good hard-working people who
are trying to make a living yeah that
doesn't justify jumping the border but
it is - that is not what President Trump
said and you know when he says things
like a Mexican judge can't be trusted
with his case because he's Mexican you
know this sort of thing is not good
outrage Alexander says I'm 21 currently
going back to schools and engineer I
work a full-time job and go to school
full time my aunt has offered to pay my
tuition might feel wrong to take it
because I'm against government's
students taking government money paying
for a higher education what would you
recommend I do well I mean I don't you
have to reject a gift from your aunt I
mean I don't think that's quite the same
thing as taking money from the
government I don't even think you have
to reject money from the government
until the system itself changes I mean I
think there are a lot of people who are
taking Pell grants and trying to pay
them back you know the availability of a
loan seems to me not an immoral thing to
take advantage of I think it's immoral
instead if you don't pay back that loan
and I don't think the loan should be
offered in the first place but those are
two separate questions as far as your an
offering to pay your tuition if you feel
wrong to take it because you feel like
you should pay your own tuition good for
you if you feel guilty taking it that's
you know your business I don't there's
anything immoral about allowing your
aunt the the pleasure of providing for
you you know when you get a gift from
your parents I don't think that's the
end of the world Chris says I'm gonna be
a new father summer next year what is a
good book to read to get prepared there
are a couple of the books you know what
Chris I'll do this next week I'm gonna
recommend a bunch of good parenting
books so instead of trying to name
off the top of my head Malthus remind me
next week when I do things I like I will
do a bunch of parenting books things
that are useful for parents to read and
you can listen to the show next week for
all of that okay we will be back here on
Monday for lots more fun and hijinks I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]